the special edition of Hannon 2020
election President Trump is in Japan for
the g20 summit where he's attending a
women's workforce session he says
anything
will bring it to you live this hour
switching gears as we continue to peruse
truth and justice and holding those that
abuse power accountable Democrats and
their partners in the media mob are
continuing to fuel more Muller mania and
impeachment fantasies take a look at
this so let me tell you we need somebody
on our stage when it comes time for that
general election who knows how to
recognize a rap sheet when they see it
and prosecute the case governor Inslee
the biggest threat to the security the
United States is Donald Trump a
president who sought to obstruct the
investigation into the invasion of our
democracy we must begin impeachment now
so that we have the facts and the truth
and we follow them as far as they go and
then the two nights of democratic
debates there was not one question on
the deep state abuse of power scandal
not one question on Faiz abuse the dirty
steal dossier or the use of secret
informants to spy on team Trump joining
me now for reaction is Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter Fox News legal
analyst Greg Jarrett and Republican
congressman Andy Biggs Greg I'll go to
you first
I think this Muller appearance on July
17th has the potential to blow up
spectacularly the Democrats face yes
what a big mistake
it's a huge mistake one of the reasons
is Muller's reports written like an op
and not a serious legal document and he
leaves a lot of things out in there one
of them being one of the contacts he
alleges is a you know Russian carve-out
format afford this guy columbic was
actually a source for the Obama State
Department to like kind of an
interesting point to bring up now yeah
he either concealed it or he
deliberately tried to deceive the
American public and the same thing with
Professor Massoud and George papadopolis
musubi it turns out isn't a Russian
agent at all works for the British
government probably and in turn the
Americans as well and then of course he
takes John's Dowd's telephone message
and he edits it down to misrepresent
that another place I found he completely
misrepresented and invented a
conversation involving Papadopoulos and
Sood and he doesn't source it he just
just made it up but he plucked it from
his own imagination so the report is
frankly disappointing in Sony ways it's
disorganized contradictory inconsistent
and it is so schizophrenic you'll get
whiplash you know it's almost a garbage
document like the dossier and what's
frustrating about it most of all are the
things he doesn't look into if he's
looking into Russian interference how
can you not look into Hillary Clinton
paying for Russian misinformation
exactly to interfere in the election but
there's none of that in there or the
dossier there's nothing in there about
Glenn Simpson and fusion GPS Brenner and
clapper all of them trying to interfere
in the election by spreading Russian
disinformation Sarah I know you've been
on this case like white on rice and one
of the things that bothers me what Greg
just said his whole shorter initial
charter Bob mullah was to investigate
Russian interference in the election and
it's convenient how he goes through
multiple pages talking about the Don
Trump jr. Trump Tower meeting with these
two Russians but Muller fails to mention
that the Russian lawyer was actually
working for the company hired by Hillary
Clinton I mean don't you think that's
kind of a key point to bring up it's a
huge point so here you have Natalya
vessel NEETs kaya the Russian write the
Russian lawyer who worked for prevas on
holdings she meets actually with Glenn
Simpson of fusion GPS the day before and
the day after and the day after that
meeting and Glenn Simpsons like no we
didn't discuss the Trump Tower meeting
at all and so these are really
significant questions that need to be
answered and let me tell you Dan I mean
the biggest point here is we're hearing
all kinds of rumors about what Robert
Moeller is going to be testifying about
how this is so significant on the part
of the Democrats this is total theater
on the part of the Democrats because
they are continuously including Andrew
McCabe who's been on MSNBC over and over
again who was basically thrown out of
the FBI for lying and fired by then
Attorney General Jeff Sessions for being
a liar and the IG caught him lying
multiple times and leaking information
to the media this is how they're trying
to keep disinformation alive by holding
this here
which is theatrical which is not gonna
resolve anything
and by the way Robert Moeller brilli
can't go outside the pervy and he
shouldn't outside the pervy of his
report so there's a lot of questions
here that need to be answered and as you
said I believe the Republicans have the
upper hand here because they can ask him
questions that are very important that
that he can answer and and there's a lot
of questions that he can't but remember
the Democrats are just trying to keep
the rumor alive it's just a rumor and
it's a lie because they have absolutely
no evidence of anything or otherwise
they would have used it yeah well nice
to people like you we know it's life
that's some great work along with you
Greg your book is just amazing
congressman Biggs you know you're up
there on the hill are they committed to
getting answers from Bob Muller I mean
one of the things that bothers me too
about his report is not just the fact
that he leaves out the $500,000 payment
from a Russian bank to Bill Clinton
that's not in there at all but also on
the exculpatory evidence front with
obstruction Donald Trump actually told
Jim call me according to his own memos
that he wanted him to investigate any
people on his team who may have been
satellites who may have been involved in
it does that sound like obstruction you
that's not in a report by the way yeah
no no it doesn't sound like obstruction
in fact there wasn't any obstruction and
I think that mr. Muller knew it but his
team was radicalized don't forget he had
a radical team that was conducting this
investigation and so they come out and
he's you know I don't know Bob Muller
from from Adams a fox but I can tell you
this the reality is mr. Muller put out a
report that is not a legal brief at all
he should never have done it the first
place the second of all it is a
basically an opinion piece but what's
going to happen I think this is going to
look a lot like the hope Hicks interview
that is you know you had Democrats
reading or asking her to read direct
quotes from the Muller report and and
the whole pigs would say well yeah
that's that's that was my statement
that's what you're gonna get with the
Democrats go to Muller you're not going
to get anything new from the Democrats
in fact Nadler has already said chairman
nailers already said hey we're gonna
probably haven't just read things this
is designed to keep up their narrative
of something that happened that there
was an obstruction of justice that
somehow just like you heard in the
debate last night somehow
the president's guilty of something
there is nothing here and they know it
that they can't get him on anything
that's criminal so they're gonna just
attack and try to sully his name with
these consistent rumors that they've
been putting out from day one Craig I
think what are the key questions to ask
Bob mauler is when exactly did you find
out that this collusion was a hoax I
mean Weissman his pit bull as they call
him he knew in August of 2016 that the
dossier had serious issues
when did Muller find that is that not
the key question within a matter of
months of his appointment may 17 2016 in
fact John Dow the president's lawyer
places it around November December of
2017 and so and there was a meeting on
March 5th 2018 a full year before the
report comes out in which according to
Dowd Muller admits that the president
has no criminal exposure over collusion
so mr. Muller why didn't you issue an
interim report isn't it true that you
wanted to keep this going to influence
unduly the 2018 interim elections so
that Democrats could take over the house
and I think that's a legitimate question
to ask also you know more inner feud
with the president the day before he
took the job as special counsel sitting
in the Oval Office isn't it true mr.
Muller that you and the president
actually discussed the reason that Comey
was fired which makes you a witness in
your own case on the obstruction
investigation Sarah just a quick last
word from you are they is the Cavill x
steele interview the Kathleen Catholic
from the State Department excuse me
where where she meets with the the
dossier with the guy in the interview
and the information is all garbage is
that going to come into play in this
Muller hearing because that information
cavil like took notes on it and it's all
discredit you think that comes up at all
oh absolutely I think the Republicans
will swoop right in on that and ask
questions about that I think this is
significantly important in those those
emails and those exchanges and Victoria
Nuland with the State Department and
what she knew are going to come up
because at that point in time
everybody knew and they questioned this
dossier which was fed to us basically by
a foreign intelligence officer from mi6
Christopher Steele who took a ton of
this information from the Russians and
now what we're discovering is that
people like Joseph Mifsud who a Greg
brought up is you know was working for
Italian and British intelligence and
we're the ones who work with them so now
we need to ask John Brennan as well what
did you know John Brennan how were you
involved in this and where did this
investigation begin well John Brennan's
in a world of trouble because that gang
of eight briefing he gave remember those
there are notes on that and that
information was only from Steele
so he's in a world of trouble Sara Craig
congressman Biggs thank you so much